okay so
there is this guy who wanted a game
one of one of my buddies
he's finally gone premium so um
so he's going to get a game
that's what it is right you go premium
and
you reap the rewards
wow explain this very confidently
so this guy i know he doesn't have the
patience to play
five minute games so that's why even
though he's a bit lower rated
i accepted a
a three minutes challenge
but he's playing he's playing well here
no complaints about the the play at all
just a very very very standard
sicilian position and so i went
for this weird a3 move on move six but
now it's fairly useful since i need to
i need to handle b4 by
by taking it okay
so i'm just gonna play quite directly
nintendo g6 now
and uh he goes g6
quite quite prudently so i'm gonna i'm
gonna put the rook back and
ask him what he he wants to do about the
threat of hg6
because then obviously he kind of take
back with the h pawns because of the pin
so he castles he castles queen side
once again
i think quite correctly
95 bishop b2 and next i think i'm going
to
castle greenside myself
you get 95 maybe
never mind 95 maybe ronson tonight b5
oh it doesn't wow that would have been
super embarrassing
so thinking knight b5 and then knight b5
but he has knight b3
check winning the queen
but this means that
knight a5 is an excellent move and i've
messed up
wow which i have to say is a bit of a
shame
how could i allow this
allow this to happen
to my once
well i wouldn't say beautiful but decent
position
that is now
maybe that's a decent no more
okay i gotta do something right just qb1
take it queen e1 so he gets to take
both of my bishops
and uh positional is doing excellently
here
two bishops are usually better than than
two nights
queen c5 another very strong move
uh
yeah the thing is if i protect on g5
he probably
probably just goes e5
and i'm losing a knight so
okay gotta gotta speed up at very least
gotta speed up
hopefully he will get nervous and blend
or something
94 now trying to hustle him
um now i get to take a d6
bring the other knight around
okay knight d3
oh this is going to be close this is
going to be real close
oh i lost the time i had queen a7
wow